and it appears voters in denmark have
said yes to the country joining the
european union's common defense policy
according to a public broadcaster exit
poll more than 69 percent have supported
the plan in a referendum now denmark is
an eu member but in the past had
negotiated an exemption on the bloc's
defense policy now against a backdrop of
russian aggression danes were asked
whether they want to opt in
so straight to dw correspondent barbara
vasil who is in copenhagen with the
latest on this referendum barbara exit
polls pointing to a yes from denmark
voting in favor of joining the eu's
common defense policy after 30 years of
opting out what is this going to mean
for denmark
it means for denmark that they have
really let go of their so deeply
ingrained skepticism against the
european union it means that they will
now come to the table with other
european countries to coordinate for
instance their weapons coordinate
missions participate in eu emissions for
instance the one in mali and another
places in the world
that they want to come inside the tent
and that maybe is the most important
point
danes have been looking at the war in
ukraine and they found it increasingly
disquieting they found that
the the time for being isolated and
being apart from others sort of loftily
saying oh we can do our own things this
time is over and they really have
changed their mind on coming back into
the fold and the fact that this was put
to a referendum is quite interesting why
is this significant for denmark
it is really significant for them
because they will now sort of be part of
the wider defense family of europe but
it also means that
the political um
atmosphere in denmark has changed that
people are looking at politics in a
different way they felt sort of
aloof they felt sort of apart from other
countries they thought they could sort
of do things that according to their own
ideas but now they find that everyone is
threatened uh it's the baltic countries
that are not that far from here
is it's finland was the very long coast
a very long coastline and borderline
towards russia
so danes feel that this war changes
everything for them it changes their
their feeling uh that they need
togetherness with others and that is a
totally new step and a real sea change
in in danish politics so is it fair to
say then that this plays into the
overall nordic shift in defense policy
uh with its neighbors sweden and finland
deciding that they want to join nato
oh absolutely because danes now think
okay finland and sweden come into nato
that means that we can form one big
defense family here in the north take in
the baltic countries norway of course
sweden finland denmark
the countries are not that big taken by
themselves but together
they can form some political they can
have some political weight and they can
sort of really sort of reinforce each
other they can have common project
objects they can sort of stand up for
each other and that really means
something to the to the self-confidence
of of danes and they are really ready
now to sort of give up all a lot of the
resilience they had in the past
against this togetherness
and it means that they have become the
slightest slightest touch more
pro-european
dw correspondent barbara faisal in
copenhagen thanks as always for your
reporting
well we've just heard sweden and finland
are pushing ahead with their landmark
bids to join nato for sweden joining the
military alliance would mean giving up
more than two centuries of neutrality
public opinion in favor of joining grew
to around 50 percent after russia
invaded ukraine
but nato member turkey opposes the bids
turkish president tayyip erdogan accuses
sweden of supporting terrorists and is
angry about stockholm's embargo on arms
sales to turkey
speaking exclusively to dw news the
swedish defense minister peter hulkfist
explained what was behind his country's
historic shift
the situation
before 24th of february was one
situation and a situation after the
russian attack against ukraine was an is
another um
we have a situation when we have a
real war in our neighborhood and
that has changed the situation
fundamentally and
we have also decided after security
analysis to go to nato membership
together with finland our values is the
same values at other countries in europe
for example germany and
and others that we we try to create
peace and we try to create peaceful
solutions but we are not naive we see
the development around us and
we must also make conclusions from from
that situation now we have the
first big war in our neighborhood since
the second world war so there is a
fundamental change and
and it's 100 percent russia's
responsibility
the swedish defense minister minister
pedro hold speaking there